vamos a usar la ecuación que acabamos de
inferir para resolver el problema que
definimos en la presentación anterior
así que escribamos de nuevo los datos
del problema
tenemos
la diferencia en distancia
queda igual a 500 metros o lo que es lo
mismo la altura de nuestro precipicio
y recuerden que es menos porque estamos
midiendo lo hacia abajo entonces como
esto es para indicar la dirección hacia
donde estamos trabajando
tenemos nuestra monedita
que en esta ocasión la vamos a lanzar o
la lanzamos hacia arriba
con una velocidad inicial de
30 metros sobre segundo esto es positivo
porque creamos que hacia arriba era
positivo y hacia abajo era negativo
y tenemos la aceleración de la gravedad
que para facilitarnos los cálculos le
redondeamos a menos
es metros sobre segundo al cuadrado pero
recordemos que el valor real es 9.8
metros entre segundo al cuadrado
y bueno también recordamos que es
negativo porque la gravedad siempre nos
jala hacia el centro de la tierra
entonces escribimos la fórmula que
encontramos en la presentación anterior
velocidad final al cuadrado
es igual a la velocidad inicial al
cuadrado más dos veces la aceleración
por el tiempo
y bueno vamos a usar la otra fórmula les
voy a cambiar el color para que resalte
esta diferencia
tenemos que ver la diferencia en
distancia es igual a la velocidad
inicial
por el tiempo
más
la aceleración por el tiempo del
cuadrado
entre dos que esta es la fórmula con la
que terminamos la presentación anterior
sustituyendo valores con los datos que
tenemos aquí tenemos que la diferencia
en distancia es igual a menos 500 metros
y esto es igual a la velocidad inicial
que quedamos que era
- pero la velocidad inicial es positiva
30 metros
sobre segundo por el tiempo
las
la aceleración que quedamos son menos 10
metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
por el tiempo al cuadrado entre 2
continuamos resolviendo tenemos que esto
es igual a 30 metros entre segundo
por el tiempo
- porque bueno tenemos menos 10 entre 2
menos
metros
en este segundo al cuadrado por el
tiempo al cuadrado ahorita para
facilitar un poco el manejo el
entendimiento de estas cuestiones voy a
omitir usar las unidades y voy a
organizar los términos de esta ecuación
para que quede de la siguiente manera
menos 500 es igual a 30 por el tiempo
menos 5 por el tiempo al cuadrado y si
ustedes han tomado ya clases de álgebra
y bueno si no consulten los vídeos que
tenemos al respecto ustedes sabrán cómo
resolver estas ecuaciones cuadráticas
aunque si ustedes no se acuerdan vamos a
ver aquí cómo resolver esta ecuación
pongamos todos los términos del lado
derecho de la ecuación para un del lado
izquierdo de la ecuación y los ordenamos
de manera que usamos el término
cuadrática más grande
5 t cuadrada acuérdense que esto cambia
el signo porque usted voy a pasar del
lado al otro lado de la igualdad
5ta y cuadrada menos 30 t
- 500
es igual a cero
y podemos dividir ambos lados de la
ecuación entre ciento para simplificar
aún más las cosas entonces 55 me queda 1
de cuadrada menos 6 de
- 100 es igual a cero entre 5 que nos
sigue quedando 10
para aquellos que necesiten un
recordatorio de cómo resolver estas
ecuaciones cuadráticas vamos a escribir
la resolución y esta la voy a cambiar en
otro color
en este caso el elemento que queremos
conocerla te vamos a descubrir que tiene
dos o que puede tener dos elementos o
dos
coeficientes
de es igual a menos de más menos raíz
cuadrada de cuadrada menos 4 a 6
y todo esto dividido entre dos a aquí
recordemos que este elemento a es el
coeficiente que acompaña al cuadra tico
en este caso tenemos un 1
el elemento b es el coeficiente que
acompaña a la t que en este caso es
menos 6 y se es la constante que tenemos
aquí como menos 100 y ahora bueno vamos
a sustituir estos valores aquí en la
ecuación
entonces tenemos que es igual a menos b
ve es -6
más menos la raíz de b cuadrada
- 4a recordemos que es 1 y se es menos
la raíz cuadrada de todo esto
entre 2 recordamos que es 1 entonces lo
dejamos como 2
ok sigamos
estos signos menos se cancelan y queda
como positivo entonces nos queda 6 +
menos raíz cuadrada 6 al cuadrado bueno
menos 6 al cuadrado que da positivo es
y este menos menos 100 también se
cancela y nos queda como más 4% 400
entre 2
nos seguimos resolviendo 6 más menos
raíz cuadrada de
436 y este no es un número o una raíz
exacta vamos a usar nuestra calculadora
para sacar la raíz cuadrada de
es igual a
20.88
vamos a ponerlo aproximado
6 -
20.8
o incluso podríamos redondear a 20.9
entre 2 y ahora no olvidemos que estamos
hablando del tiempo
entonces imagínense que de estos dos
términos del 6
más menos
20 puntos 9 entre 2 aproximado
si nosotros eligiéramos a hacer este
elemento en la resta 6 menos 20 me va a
dar un número negativo lo que en este
contexto del problema que estamos
hablando de tiempo pues no tiene sentido
hablar de un tiempo negativo entonces
bueno sabiendo esto esta condición vamos
a ver que la única respuesta que tiene
sentido es sumar estos elementos lo que
nos queda que el tiempo es
aproximadamente igual a
26.9 entre 2
y usamos la calculadora
nos queda
13.45
entonces
el tiempo es aproximadamente igual a
13.45
seguros
bueno aquí ya estoy incorporando las
unidades porque se acuerdan que las
quité para facilitar los cálculos si
quieren verificar que las unidades están
correctas pueden repetir estos cálculos
incluyendo las unidades para que vean
que queda esta cantidad
esto es interesante este resultado de
13.45 segundos si ustedes recuerdan hace
4 o 5 vídeos cuando vimos este problema
dejando caer la moneda simplemente
soltando la desde el acantilado en este
problema yo les di el tiempo que era de
10 segundos para llegar al suelo y así
encontramos que el precipicio tenía una
altura de 500 metros bueno si ustedes
están en lo alto de un edificio de 500
metros y deja un ganado pequeño como una
moneda que casi no tiene resistencia al
aire entonces le tomaría 10 segundos
para llegar al suelo pero si lance en la
moneda hacia arriba a unos 30 metros por
segundo de velocidad le tomara 13.45
segundos o sea casi 13 y medio segundos
en llegar al suelo vamos a dibujar aquí
un momento él les va a hacer el dibujo
de los precipicios para que entiendan lo
que les estoy explicando
entonces tenemos que en el primer
problema en el primer caso tenemos
nuestro precipicio
y aquí les teníamos la moneda y
simplemente la dejamos caer
y en el siguiente bueno en el segundo
problema tenemos a ellos aquí el
precipicio medio chueco
pero la moneda en lugar de dejarla caer
primero la lanzamos hacia arriba
y después pues obviamente por la fuerza
de la gravedad pues de esta manera y
bakker bueno ok
entonces pues vemos que aquí por ejemplo
encontramos que la distancia del
precipicio era de 500 metros
y el tiempo era de 10 segundos lo que
tardaba en caer de aquí hacia acá sin
embargo vemos que la distancia que
recorre aquí la moneda cuando lo
lanzamos en el aire pues sin duda es
mayor a 500 metros
entonces es lógico que se tarden más
tiempo en recorrer más distancia por eso
es que el tiempo nos quedó mayor que en
el primer caso pero de 13
punto 45 segundos
si este número viene salido menor
entonces ustedes tendrían que haber
revisado sus operaciones pues cómo
podría tomar menos tiempo el objeto si
lo lance hacia arriba y tiene más
distancia que recorrer bueno espero que
con esto quede más claros los conceptos
pues de ahora ya tienen en su accionar
todas las fórmulas y espero que el
entendimiento necesario para resolver
los problemas de movimiento de
proyectiles en los siguientes vídeos
resolveremos varios problemas para dejar
bien claros estos conceptos y después
expandiremos los problemas para ver cómo
resolverlos cuando se tienen varias
dimensiones y diferentes ángulos y para
ello les recomiendo que refrescan sus
conocimientos de trigonometría nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo